Huyen 6 trường đông gián hồn đến từ giới chức và cắt chuyên gia khu vực trở biệt,
cuối xung độc Israel i Van Hồi thằng sáo vừa qua,
đã gây tự thải cho chúng chính trình hạp nhân của Tây Van,
Ê thân nhiều sọng hơi sự kiến,
làm giấy lây lo ngày về một vòng xung độc mới.
Theo các chuyên gia i Van hiện giả hữu khó,
u ran yu làm sáo cao, đồ để chế thảo khoảng người một vô khi hạp nhân.
Tuy nhiên, về chi chính xác của số vấn lều này vẫn chưa được gia đình gió.
Một số cuối gia vùng vệnh tình rằng Israel có thể mở của tấn công mới,
đã biệt khi Iran bị nghĩ là đang xây dẫn cứ sở làm sáo u ran y mới
và tích tục tư cho hợp tác,
bởi các thằng sát biển của Tây.
Ông ál yv然 giám đông giữa Iran thủ nhóm khu hạn của Tây Xe Cơ,
trên biệt,
tay Iran đã tăng tóc sản xuất tên luật,
và chuẩn bị cho khả năng đối đầu.
Chúng ta nói Israel cho là đang cân nhát phản nữ mạng mạng hồn,
làm ra tăng xe cơ sư lộn tại khu vực trường đông.